Welcome to "This is Madness:..."
"...The Star Wars Character Tournament."
We would be honored if you would join us in "This is Madness!"
You will be presented with matchups featuring heroes on the light side...
...and quote, unquote "villains" on the dark side.
You don't know the power of the... sorry where was I?
Oh yes, the tournament.
You must vote for your favorite hero or villain in each matchup.
Whoever receives the most votes will advance in the tournament...
...until he or she is crowned champion of "This is Madness!"
Now for my pitch.
With your backing, I will win this competition and crush all who stand in my way.
Together, we will unleash the power of the dark side...
...and I will have bragging rights over both Obi-Wan and the emperor which is pretty awesome.
So, as much as I hate democracy, vote now, vote often and vote Vader.
It is the only way.